December 1944 in the city of Bastogne
Belgium during the Battle of the Bulge
American soldiers primarily from the
hundred and first Airborne Division but
also from the nine 69th artillery
battalion and combat command B of the
tenth Armored Division were surrounded
by Germans they were outnumbered by
approximately five to one they were
lacking in cold weather gear they were
short on ammunition and low on food and
medical supplies the weather was
horrible
due to heavy cloud cover resupply from
the air was not possible they appeared
to be doomed that is certainly what the
Germans thought so on the 22nd of
December the Germans sent a message with
two young German officers offering an
opportunity for the Americans to
surrender the message read to the USA
commander of the encircled town of
Bastogne the fortune of war is changing
this time the USA forces in and near
Bastogne have been encircled by strong
German armored units more German armored
units have crossed the river or feu near
or through Ville have taken Marche have
reached st. who bear by passing through
hombre cebre till a Libra malt is in
German hands there is only one
possibility to save the encircled us a
troops from Total Annihilation
that is honorable surrender of the
encircled town in order to think it over
a term of two hours will be granted
beginning with the presentation of this
note if this proposal should be rejected
one German artillery Corps and six heavy
AAA battalions are ready to annihilate
the USA troops in and near Bastogne the
order for firing will be given
immediately after this two hours term
all the serious civilian losses caused
by this artillery fire would not
correspond with the well-known American
humanity signed the German commander the
American commander General Anthony
McAuliffe upon hearing this offer didn't
like the idea at all in fact his initial
response was simply nuts after a little
discussion with his staff on what the
proper written response would be they
decided that was the proper response so
they put together a formal note on
letterhead to return to the German
commander it read 22 December 1944 to
the German commander nuts signed the
American commander on Christmas Eve
general McAuliffe sent out a message to
his troops in the besieged city it read
headquarters hundred first Airborne
Division the office of the division
commander 24 December 1944 what's merry
about all this you ask
we're fighting it's coal
we aren't home all true but what has the
proud Eagle Division accomplished with
it's worthy comrades of the tenth
Armored Division the 750 ank destroyer
battalion and all the rest just this
we have stopped cold everything that has
been thrown at us from the north east
south and west
we have identifications from four German
Panzer divisions two German infantry
divisions and one German parachute
division these units spearheading the
last desperate German lunge were headed
straight west for key points when the
Eagle Division was hurriedly ordered to
stem the advance how effectively this
was done will be written in history not
alone in our divisions glorious history
but in world history the Germans
actually did surround us their radios
blared our doom their commander demanded
our surrender in the following impudent
arrogance and that's when the general
added in the note of the Germans
surrender demand and he gave his
response the simple response of nuts he
wanted all the troops to know then then
he closed out the memo explaining their
current situation on the ground the
message continued Allied troops are
counter-attacking in force we continued
to hold Bastogne by holding Bastogne we
assure the success of the Allied armies
we know that our division commander
general Taylor will say well done we are
giving our country and our loved ones at
home
a worthy Christmas present and being
privileged to take part in this gallant
feat of arms are truly making for
ourselves
a Merry Christmas AC McAuliffe well the
Germans did attack Bastogne on Christmas
Day and they did initially break through
the American perimeter but the American
soldiers stood their ground and defeated
the attack eventually destroying all the
German tanks then the next day the 26th
of December General Patton's 4th Armored
Division along with the 26th Infantry
Division broke through to Bastogne and
opened up a corridor to relieve the
embattled but victorious troops it was a
glorious example of will and defiance
and undaunted courage in the face of
seemingly insurmountable odds and it was
an example of the victory of light over
darkness but let us never forget that
for every victory there is a cost there
is sacrifice and one letter home also
written
on Christmas Eve December 24th 1944 from
the Battle of the Bulge by Lieutenant
Colonel Arthur Blair the commanding
officer of the 268 Field Artillery
Battalion who was born in New Orleans
and raised in Mississippi this letter
shows some of that sacrifice the letter
was written to Colonel Blair's parents
but in the letter he also speaks of his
young wife Mary and their three-year-old
daughter Susan this is what he wrote
dear folks
well so this is Christmas Eve I've spent
a lot of lonely ones those when I've
been away from you and Merry but I've
never spent one quite this lonely and
one in which the Christmas spirit seemed
so lacking in the surroundings even the
first one of the war with Mary leaving
the next day was not so bad as this one
then I had things to worry about and
lots of work to do but here everything
is as it has been the same day-in
day-out routine and all I have to think
of is how much I miss you and Mary and
Susie and what fun and how comfortable
and right it would be if we were all
spending Christmas Eve and Christmas
together we will have turkey tomorrow
then some of the men will have received
Christmas packages and that will be the
extent of our Christmas there is no
peace around us no peace in our hearts
the Christmas star is an airplane flare
the three wisemen where are they now
there's nothing here but anger in men's
hearts the wisest men are those who do
the best job of killing the enemy while
avoiding death themselves the main Jers
are corrupt with dead and rotting cattle
and the village ends gape at the night
through the glass windows and tireless
roofs the gifts of the Magi are steel
and flame and high explosives but deep
in my heart I know that peace will come
again and families will again be
together for God and his son are
watching over us and protecting us all
as well as we will let them so in the
hope of tomorrow and the peace to come
dear dad and mom merry Christmas to you
and a happy and peaceful new year all my
love your son Arthur
well Arthur did not make it home to be
with his family again the next day
Christmas 1944 as he was wishing the
officers and men of his battalion and
Merry Christmas a German shell hit
wounding several of the men and killing
Colonel Arthur W Blair he was one of the
19 thousand Americans killed in the
Battle of the Bulge
in one of the thousands upon thousands
upon thousands that have died for our
flag and the ideals of freedom that it
represents
colonel Blair's executive officer wrote
a letter to the family and said the
memory of the colonel is one that will
always be kept green by those who knew
him and had served with him he was an
outstandingly gallant officer a fine
leader and above all else
a true gentleman on the field of battle
where there can be no sham he proved it
beyond the question of a doubt and the
executive officer signed off the letter
quoting Shakespeare when Horatio bid a
final farewell to his friend
Hamlet now cracks a noble heart
goodnight sweet prince and flights of
angels sing thee to thy rest
- all those noble souls that left us too
young and cracked our hearts we bid you
the same goodbye may flights of angels
sing you to your rest we will remember
you always and we are thinking of you
this holiday season Merry Christmas
and a Happy New Year to all and may
there be peace on earth